[Music]
we all come across many target based
situations in our day-to-day life can
you think of any say a student has to
complete a project in 15 days or a
salesperson has to achieve a sales
target within a month another person has
to buy an electronic gadget within a
budget of $500 go through these
situations and try to find out the main
object to be achieved by each person
individually what is the objective of
the student in this case yes she wants
to achieve the maximum score in this
project can you tell me the objective of
a salesperson in this case yes he would
aim to achieve maximum possible sales in
a month what do you think would be the
objective of the person buying a gadget
she would try to minimize the cost as
much as possible
she'd buy a gadget that falls within her
budget we can see that in each of the
cases above the objective of the
situation was to maximize the benefits
or minimize the cost such types of
problems are solved as optimization
problems in mathematics does an
optimization problem may involve finding
maximum profit minimum cost or maybe
minimum use of resources there can be
many more examples from our day to day
life which need to be solved using the
optimization technique the problems can
be as simple as stated above but could
get complex depending on the situation
we have already discussed about the
objectives of the three given situations
now we will look at the other important
factors we will identify the limiting
factors in each case what does that mean
well in each case there is a scarcity of
some resource like in the first case the
time limit to complete the project is
limited time to be allotted for
completing the project is limited to 15
days only likewise in this case to tie
is the limiting factor the salesperson
has to sell the maximum possible
products in a period of one month what
can you say about the third situation
what's the limiting factor in this case
the person has to buy the gadget within
a pre-decided budget that means the
amount to be spent or money is the
limiting factor in this case these
limiting factors that is the scarce
resources act as constraints in finding
the best possible solution of the given
problem in simple words the aim of the
optimization problem is to find the
optimum solution subject to constraints
of the given problem this means we need
to find the best possible outcome by
allocating the scarce resources but how
are these optimization problems solved
in mathematics there are different
problem-solving techniques to solve such
problems they come from a very important
area of mathematics called as
optimization techniques yes there are
many different categories of the
optimization techniques some of them can
be seen here one such technique that we
will discuss in our upcoming lessons is
linear programming
what is linear programming how is it
used to solve the optimization problems
let's find the answers to these
questions in our next lesson
[Music]
you